hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to this mind f of a
game all of this cool yeah yeah narrator
you shut your trap hole Stan I decided
to go to the museum I'm not gonna do a
damn thing you say I'm going my own path
I'm not even gonna wait for you to talk
to me and stab me through you to open
this was not the correct way to shut up
and standing you imperfect shut up Stan
Lee's gonna win this by the employee
lounge first just to admire it God the
last the last ending was so freakin meta
what I can't even imagine I can't even
you own this gorgeous room I can't even
deal with it any goodness can taken this
deal on his way to the meeting room life
without having experienced this room was
now too horrible even to consider yes
absolutely
however I think there's something else
to this room something else here really
really worth it being here in the room
okay shut up I'm moving on so I but
eager to get shot isn't it up Stanley
took the first open door on his left
yeah I'm gonna do it and so he detoured
through the maintenance section walked
straight ahead to the opposite door and
got back on track
No
I don't know where this leads but it's
my choice I choose what I do not you but
Stanley didn't want to go back to the
office no he wanted to wander about and
get even further off track yes so now in
order to get back he needed to go um
yeah left are you sure about that
what about right a man I don't know if
you're right about this one alright I'll
trust you no no no it's to the right my
mistake how about you not be such a dick
no why would I have ever said it was to
the right what was I thinking it's
clearly oh dear what you hold on for a
minute ok yes I've got it now this story
is absolutely definitely this way are
you sure that it is this way but this
way only seems to lead through this way
that door doesn't even go anywhere so
confused again again I am confused
I do not whoa no no no no no no this
isn't right at all you're not supposed
to be here yet this is all a spoiler
extent Lee close your eyes
okay back to him Oh Who am I kidding
it's all rubbish now call story
completely unusable Paulo Bob rather
than waste my time trying to salvage
this nonsense
we'll just restart the game from the
beginning time suppose we don't wander
so far off track
hmm no from the top hey how about you
stop be such a douche to me let me make
all of this coworkers I'm gonna go the
same damn way I'm gonna go the exact
same way to the meeting this guy if this
game what wait wait what well no no I
restarted I swear I definitely restarted
completely fresh well everything should
be did something change Stanley did you
change anything when we were back in
that room with all the monitors did you
move the story somewhere or I'm the one
who wrote the story was right here just
a minute ago I don't know I know for
sure that it's here somewhere
are you sure okay then it's an adventure
let's find the story by the toe if he
hollers let him go I hate the game
vanish no that's the same door yes screw
you
I don't know what oh god my brain I said
this is the worst adventure I've ever
been on I can promise you there
definitely was a story here before what
do we just do we need to restart the
game again now what I find it unlikely
that we'll ever progress by starting
over again
but it's got to be better than this hey
okay let's give it a shot why not why Oh
I was getting no I wasn't getting
anywhere okay now let me do my thing all
of his co-workers were gone yeah yeah it
it mean Stanley decided to go to the
meeting room perhaps he had simply
missed a memo yeah whatever
store over now okay
what's gonna change this time I'm so
confused
Oh God it's worse I might be remembering
this wrong it's possible the story is
back where we just came from why don't
we go back the other direction and see
if we missed anything
Oh back this way it's how what you want
me to do well there's this door open
there but I don't know what woody might
what am I doing here
well hey I don't think this is right
aha I knew we'd miss something the story
here it comes
what wait a minute no wait
oh my mind a story okay let's head back
the other way and retrace our steps ah
dude I don't trust you anymore not that
I ever did but something's obviously
messed up here at Oh Oh God now this
Milad be honest I didn't recognize this
place at all oh is this the story I
don't think so
I can't quite recall but I believe my
story took place in an office building
it is that correct hmm this looks like
some stories I've heard of what do you
know what since I've completely
forgotten what were you were supposed to
be doing how about this you win work and
it really paid off so good job I'm the
best thank you couldn't have done it
without you big guy no I don't feel
right about this at all yeah no you
didn't put in any actual work for a win
some people win fair and square
and this was not one of those situations
okay I'm getting weirded out by whatever
this place is yeah what might happen
this time I have to restart okay oh god
the adventure line this this is gonna be
good
all right I've got a solution this time
to make sure we don't get lost I've
employed the help of the Stanley parable
adventure line okay wait let's follow
the line how simple is that
wait what what's over here
Oh what's over here no no I'm done we're
living it up to the line from now on
okay sorry sorry to bother you I'll go
back to the line wow this looks
promising zigzag you see the line knows
where the story is there's over in this
direction
um what Stanley to destiny uh dude
here's a thought wouldn't wherever we
end up be our destination even if
there's no story there or to put in
another way is the story of no
destination still a story what simply by
the act of moving forward are we
implying a journey such that a
destination is inevitably conjured into
being by the very manifestation of the
nature of life itself okay Stanley I
need to follow this train of thought for
a minute just stick with me
what now we can both agree that the
nature of existence is in fact a
byproduct of one subjective experience
of that existence right okay now if my
experience of your existence rests
inside of your subjective experience of
this office is this office in fact the
skeleton of my own relative ex parental
mental subjective construed weird back
there well I'd like to apologize Oh not
sure where I was going with all that hey
you know what I think what we need right
now is a bit of music to lighten the
mood
much better
music go back and look at that fern well
there's fern Danny
this phone will be very important later
in the story make sure you study it
closely and remember it carefully you
won't want to miss anything
I'll save here so I can come back to
this fern because it is important
Oh God the adventure line what no lion
you do know we're looking for the
Stanley parable right yeah sorry
is any of this ringing a bell
wait what's back over here hey wait no
give me a second amount is something I
think something changed over here I was
still missing the doors did we make a
mistake following the line perhaps we
could have found the story on our end no
I don't think so mister I think you
could have killed me on your own but
that's about it
Phil let's just let's let's get through
with this okay teamwork about Oh God how
could you have done this to us
and after we trusted you after
everything we've been through you well I
can't take this anymore to hell with it
restart Oh God again wait so are we
following the line or not are we doing
this dude you know what Stan what I say
forget the adventure line once it ever
done for us we're intelligent people
right yeah why can't we make up our own
story yeah exciting daring mysterious oh
this wall sounds perfectly doable why
don't we simply start wandering in well
I don't know how about this direction
ooh I like it but what about this
direction with this in or this alright
fine we'll go your way oh geez fine I'm
trusting you on this one yes this is
exciting yeah just me and Stanley
forging a new path a new story anything
ya want our story
to be wild Oh who's your imagination uh
whatever it might be Stanley what I'm
ready for it um there was once a gopher
and he had teeth that are way too big
and all the other Gophers like what dude
Oh Stanley I'd also like to veto the
line from having any role in our awesome
news story but I no lines or monitor
rooms just don't acknowledge it
Oh should be fine okay I'm not looking
at it I'm not looking at it Oh God look
at it
Oh God oh it's the Slenderman I'm not
looking at it okay good there we go
where did it go oh I see good for you
line two stay awesome work ah a choice
we get to make a decision
well I'm here the story is in our
control how important we mustn't
squander the opportunity in fact I
believe I need a minute to think here
okay just walk in circles for a minute
what okay
so I know that each door has to lead
somewhere which means that somewhere the
place where we're trying to go there
must be a reversed door that leads he
knows where and that in turn means that
our destination corresponds with that
counter inverted reversed doors origin
so starting from the right let us ask
will taking the right door lead us to
where we're going and since the answer
is clearly yes then by all accounts the
door on the right is the correct one
another victory for logic come Stanley
our destiny awaits okay okay hmm the
confusion ending you're telling me
that's what this is it's all one giant
ending and we're supposed to restart the
game book eight eight times that's
really how all this goes what it's all
determined
so now according to the schedule I
restart again then what am I supposed to
forget well what if I don't want to
forget my mind goes blank simply because
it's written here on this this thing
oh he's gonna forget well who consulted
me where do I get to decide why don't I
get a say in all of this is it really no
it can't be ID I don't want it to be a I
don't want the game to keep restarting I
don't want to forget what's going on
okay I don't want to be trapped like
this I like it won't restart the game I
won't do it I won't do it I won't do it
don't mean them to be do it did we break
the cycle the whatever it is that made
this schedule yeah how would we even
know
well someone come for us well something
happened
oh no no so okay so you're control man
guess now we just wait you know I
suppose in some way that this is a kind
of story wouldn't you agree
oh I'm not quite sure if we're in the
destination or journey though they're
always saying that life is about the
journey and not the destination so I
hope that's where we are right now well
find out won't we eventually well in the
mean god no oh god he's forgotten oh no
all of his co-workers were gone oh now
do you mean Stanley decided to go to the
meeting room oh no her haps he had
simply missed a memo the rest of the
things said that he'd forgotten I
wouldn't be able to throw anything Oh
when Stanley came to a set of two open
doors he entered the door on his left
this was not the correct way and
standing you it perfectly well yeah
there perhaps he wanted to stop by the
employee lounge first just do it mom
wait the lounge was sublime a work of
art what was it about this room deeply
and so personally to Stanley grace its
subtle charm no Stanley knew it was
something deeper something but eager to
get back to business
Stanley took the first open door on his
land the adventure line
okay STEMI was so bad at following
direct I got my brain
I gotta stop anyway cuz I'm all at a
time oh good but anyway thank you all so
much for watching I'm gonna fear this
out in the next one
oh god my brain is oozing into my
headphones so thank you all so much for
watching click the end phase and more
videos that I've done and as always see
you in the next video